this is a face sprinkles mini palette  from designer dustco the Glitter has a  vegan gel base that dries down you can  apply it on the face hair or body I was  having fun just putting it everywhere  Milani released this conceal and perfect  line first I tried the brightener under  my concealer I didn't notice much  brightening at first but then I applied  it with my fingertips and got some  better coverage next I tried the liquid  Contour this color does lean a little  bit red but it Blended out really  beautifully and added a nice warmth to  my face I applied the highlighter next  and I loved this it doesn't add any  texture to my skin it just gave a really  pretty glow these are the collidos  Epiphany glow Melton eyeliners Melton  was the perfect description for these  because they really do glide on so  easily but these are really beautiful  and I highly recommend them